pardon me for not remembering his name
but Terence McKenna's brother
um has been doing a great deal yeah
Dennis is doing a lot of great work down
south I believe in Central America
and setting up an Institute and a
college uh to study these things their
effects in a pragmatic scientific and
fashion utilizing control groups and
modern therapy I think that's very
important because it it is the the
Undiscovered Country of human
consciousness is to go down the rabbit
hole of of loss of self frankly
um now does that tie directly into what
we see in the skies and what we purport
to and what we hope might be have
crashed pardon me for hoping a crash on
anyone but hoping that there might be
evidence right you know we all hope that
there's that eventually some day we
might find that that Smoking Gun we all
talk about that gives us clarity
but
I still don't know if the Spectrum we're
looking at I feel like our needle goes
all over the place all the time because
we're using a word like phenomena and I
think that's important I think I think
the the facile idea that we have taken
the word UFO and replaced it with some
new no we used a better word because
most of the stuff that I am encountering
regardless of whether it's unidentified
or an object it's certainly not
exhibiting flight characteristics and
that just gets under my skin that we're
constantly saying flight flying flying
listen that's a that's a kindergarten
attitude to think it's in the sky it's
flying it's I'm sorry to say it like
that if that's not
that we need folks to to get out of that
muck get get get up get up a level on
some of this stuff it really opens up
new doors of thought it opens up new
possibilities as to what we're working
with when you start looking at it
differently and not in the science
fiction and as you've been told aspect
I agree and we need to be more accurate
with our terminology right this goes
back to what Sean was saying in the
beginning as far as our lexicon you know
please you know be accurate when you
when you speak because it you know what
words have meaning and and a lot of
people just kind of throw words around
and you know they're not really doing
their due diligence understanding and it
confuses things and and you know we have
to be accurate that's why science is is
to where it is today because it involves
accuracy math right
um you want to be accurate when you're
when you're describing things like this
especially something that we don't know
be accurate in the unknowns um and I
think that's you know Sean Sun said it
perfectly you know you have flight is a
fundamental you have four fundamental
forces you have thrust lift drag and
weight and when you understand those you
have flight you have control surfaces
you have wings and and Rudders and
ailerons and elevators but we're not
seeing any of those Associated
Technologies and people say well it's a
semantics no it's it it is but it's
important it's important semantics right
otherwise just call every animal an
animal right forget if it's a blue whale
or a human being or an elephant it's
just an animal well no there's
differences key differences and we have
to be we have to be mindful of that
yeah I like to say on this podcast
there's this word that people say with
denigration it's acquittity now
acquittity means it's a hair splitting
distinction but it also means A peculiar
Essence an odd feature in eccentricity
something that sets it apart and so I'm
a fan of delineation